today we're going to be talking about a
couple fellows who
do exactly that they're uh young fellows
that
are the new generation of mathematical
physics just coming out of college
trying to make a living you know in the
mathematical physics world and what they
do is they uh
put shows on uh youtube
and uh what they do is essentially um
disperse you know diffuse the uh
of mathematical physics okay
and i talked about one of these fellows
the other day his name is nick
lucid and i gave a brief um
i gave a brief uh bio of him uh he's a
curly look alike talks
like curly uh of the three stooges uh
got a masters in mathematics out of
some university he didn't clarify that
uh
possibly in michigan i think he lives in
michigan
he's got a youtube channel the science
asylum and that's
i think a good title because i think he
recognizes that
science is crazy it's crazy only because
they do everything with particles and
because they do
uh the reification
of uh concepts and um
yeah essentially he regurgitates quantum
mechanics and general relativity
for the masses okay and so well he he
does
his living there well let me keep put
him up there still
and this other fella uh his name is
derek
muller and he's also been around for a
little while now and what
he does the same thing he's got a
channel he's called
verizon very sitacion
he's got a phd in mathematics out of the
university of sydney
and his thesis with designing effective
multimedia for
physics education so obviously he's into
convincing and persuading people
and that's what he does best what does
he persuade him on well the same thing
as this other fellow on the left of
quantum mechanics
and general relativity primarily okay
and uh yeah he is a youtube celebrity
he's uh
got that site versus potassium and he's
famous for
discovering the 113th element
and i think he's going to get a nobel
prize for that
okay uh you know there's 112 elements
that they've
essentially they say they discovered
when you look at the
periodic table on the internet you only
find them up to
103
and then from 104 to 112
you got to look them up they're not
there
i guess someone forgot i don't know most
most uh
most of these sites don't have most of
the um
what is it the uh periodic tables that
you see uh on the internet
uh don't show the those elements uh
but uh this while he invented the 100 or
discovered the 113th element here it is
okay where is itacium okay
and um what is that what is various
potassium well it's the
element of truth that's what he
discovered the element of truth
so you can see uh where he's gonna go
with this he's gonna talk about truth
and fact and proof okay
that's uh typical of mathematical
physics that's what he was taught that's
what he regurgitates okay
okay he got into a little squabble i
guess with this other fella
really i'm creating the squabble uh
because
one guy repeated the same thing as the
other guy and the question is
who did it first okay so here you have
these two
gentlemen mr lucid on the left and mr
mueller on the right
and the only difference there they have
uh their uh
magnetic fields or i'm sorry the
electric fields the
electricity pointing in different
directions uh what i'm trying to
recommend
is that people get away from using the
plus and minus sign that seems to con
fuse a lot of people out there for
magnetism and electricity
i think they should use the uh the
multiplication sign and the division
sign
after all you know when you multiply
it's a lot faster
and when you divide it's a lot faster
than you know subtracting and so on
so you know that's a recommendation on
my part
you can also use square root instead of
negative and positive and maybe powers
something like that
okay keep that in mind you know instead
of north and south pole we'll call it
the
multiplication poll the division poll
okay here we have uh
these two gentlemen they uh vouch for
special relativity today
uh they say that special relativity has
something
to do with electricity and with
magnetism
that's what caught my attention okay and
here they are they
essentially uh synthesize it here right
says if you pass an uh mr mueller first
if you pass an electric current through
any metal it becomes a magnet an
electromagnet but how
this how does this work well strangely
enough it is a consequence of
special relativity i thought special
relativity in general
or general relativity in general had had
to do with the cosmic world out there
you know they were trying to explain all
that stuff
uh well special relativity could be an
exception
but he says that magnetism and
electricity
have to do with relativity
now that's really curious i'm interested
i'm
caught my attention and uh mr lucid says
you can't
uh understand electromagnetism without
special relativity
my god you know i mean they they went to
the same school
same monastery priest taught him the
same thing
and the big issue here is i see it is
who who said it first
you know and i kind of vouch for mr uh
derek muller because
he did his in 2013 whereas uh
uh mr nick uh lucid he he came in a few
years late he did in what is it
i think 2019 so if
if we're going to compare them i think i
would put my bet
on on the fellow on the left because he
said how special relativity makes
magnets work
and the other fella says how special
relativity fixed electromagnetism
six years later in fact on september 11
9 11
and maybe he was celebrating something
okay
so um well uh what is special relativity
well here you have a little quick
synopsis of
what it is uh essentially special
relativity is general relativity without
gravity uh you know you never you can
never fall
down in flatland and so uh special
relativity is the world of flat land
and uh general relativity is the world
of the flat universe
so don't confuse them please don't
confuse flat universe with flat land
okay
uh two different things uh so
a couple of the things that special
relativity is famous for
is length contraction mass increase in
time dilation
and i'll cover the first two there
length contraction if you travel
close to the speed of light they claim
that your ruler contracts in the
direction of travel
likewise if you uh travel close to the
speed of light
your mass increases okay
and um the question is when you come
back to
normal speed like you slowed down and
come back to earth you went to
to mars or whatever the speed of light
and then came back or you went to a
black hole or whatever
you know uh then come back to earth
well are you has your your ruler grown
back again
has your the quantity of matter
got back into your body did you lose
quantity of matter when you traveled and
then recovered it
when you came back to earth in other
words are these
real or cosmetic uh interpretations
that's the issue and what they do is
they pull out their equations their
calculators their slide rulers and they
say let me
let me show you they calculate
okay so you calculate and there's a
difference okay that's not a question
the question is there a real
contraction is there a real mass
increase
i mean are we putting more pounds on
meaning more matter
are we losing that matter when we come
back to an inertial frame of reference
to a
point where you're standing still right
and so that's that's a question a lot of
people have asked over the years there's
been a debate
and an endless debate
between whether it's real or fictitious
and let me tell you what the problem is
if it's fictitious if it's uh if it's
cosmetic then nobody cares
nobody cares about special relativity
the only
reason they make it care the
mathematicians make it care
make it be worth it's your while is they
say no it's real it's a real contraction
and the ru in the case of the ruler and
it's a real mass increase
meaning what because they never define
mass but
if you go out there and ask anybody from
high school etc they'll say well yeah
mass is the
quantity of matter or a measure of the
quantity of matter
so did we add more quantity of matter
while traveling and if you travel faster
and faster and faster and faster and
faster
almost at the speed of light are you
gonna bloat like a
you know like an elephant
so this is this is the issue with these
people you know are we talking real or
or fictitious if it's fictitious who
cares
yeah yeah do your calculation there and
don't bother us
but now these people come into physics
and say no these uh
effects are real that's where we have a
little bit of problem
and what these two fellows are going to
do they're going to incorporate
these notions especially the length
contraction
uh into physics into their
analysis of electricity okay
and that's where i have a little bit of
problems
okay yeah okay so nick's get started
nick
uh lucid he gets started first and he
starts off on the wrong foot really
because
he's gonna start with the word field
okay
keep that in mind so here we go with a
field okay
this is what mr lucid says he says um
things like magnets and charges can
exert forces on each other over a
distance
that kind of that kind of seems it kind
of seems
like magic which is a problem these two
fields
are a way for us to avoid that problem
oh so he's going to avoid the problem by
introducing the word field okay
they act kind of like a middleman or
intermediary
one charge creates a field and it's that
field which that
actually which that actually exerts a
force on the other charge the whole
purpose of those fields is to explain
force at a distance
and he continues as the maxwell heavy
side equations tell us how fields are
made
well we got a problem right off the bat
because he's going to use the word field
as a physical object okay he's going to
say that it's the mediator and with it
he's going to explain what
action at a distance something that no
mathematician on planet earth has been
able to explain in the last 400 years
only with a rope model do you have
actually no action at a distance just
that you can't see the mediator
but these people talk about action at a
distance since they
uh don't want to put a little spirit in
there you know little angel or
god's you know black magic in there they
say
well it was done with energy or it was
done with mass or it was done with a
field
this file is going to use the field so
what is a field okay
let's find out okay we look it up make
sure we understand what he's talking
about
says a field is a physical quantity
a bunch of numbers that's what a field
is represented by a number or tensor
that has a value for each point in space
and time so we're talking about a bunch
of values
surrounding something it could be a
gravitational field could be an electric
field
magnetic field what they're talking
about is a bunch of values that they can
measure
that get stronger and stronger as they
as you approach
the center of the object that's
uh that all these bees are humming
around okay
and i like uh what someone put in quora
he said the effects of fields are
observed but nobody knows what physical
process
is causing the effects of fields this is
one of the many
unresolved mysteries of science and is a
subject of ongoing research
now nobody's researching fields they
they've
ever since faraday invented the word
they've been using the word field they
in fact they extended it to gravity
because until then it was used for
first for magnetism then for electricity
eventually
for um for uh gravity
and nobody's researching the word field
so so if you're waiting
for someone to tell you you know what is
a field you're gonna wait
uh a billion years that i would think
you know till the big crunch nobody's
ever going to tell you what a field is
because no one's researching these kinds
of subjects anymore
okay right now they just use whatever
they've got out there and they fly
fly with that with those notions
okay uh so this is uh
what people usually think of when they
think of a field the mathematicians
that's the physical notion some
three-dimensional cobweb in there that
extends all the way to the edges of
space-time and then that's what they're
going to be doing their
magical gravity in electricity and
magnetism with
but see when you look at that definition
that you just saw this is what you get
okay you get a bunch of numbers values
okay i didn't put the units because i
think it's irrelevant the
the point that i want to make here is
that i feel there's a bunch of vibrating
numbers
uh they're they're numbers that are
surrounding an object that's how it is
center of the objects uh more intense
and farther away less intense
whatever a field is in other words it's
a mathematical
uh contraption and they refer to it as
sometimes as a mathematical object no
they put the word object to suggest to
you that they're talking about physics
they're not they're talking about math
but they want to give you a physical
interpretation so they say well just
imagine that's
this cobweb that's out there and let's
not worry too much about that let's
continue with math
or with the this description because all
they can do is describe
yeah they don't they never identify the
field they never will
and so personally i don't think that uh
mr lucid
uh can tell the difference between a um
wheat field and a marijuana field okay
because he says
a magnetic field is one reference frame
could easily be an electric field in
another or even some combination of them
in a third and he says the same thing
for force
and that's what he's going to try to
show in his
uh video in which he talks about special
relativity
having something to do with
electromagnetism
yes all these people bring these fields
whatever
field is because we don't all we know is
that there are a bunch of numbers
but when they bring them into physics
now what are they talking about
are they going to continue talking about
a bunch of numbers no what they do is
they try to illustrate the field for you
so that you can get a
glimpse of what they're talking about
and that's when they commit the crime of
the century
that's when they uh you know veer off at
the left field
okay both these fellows uh
nick and um
derrick they start out with this in
their
presentations they start out with what i
showed the other day
an electric circuit essentially they say
look you know what you have there
is all these electron beads going from
atom to atom
from one side of the battery to the
other from one
side of the source to another could be
you know electric uh electrical outlet
in your house essentially that's it very
simple you know you have all the
electron beads going from adam's atom
that's been the notion of uh
mathematical physics for electricity
um at least i'd say the last almost 200
year 150 years okay
that's the notion people have that it's
a flow of particles that's what
everybody's taught
okay okay so they simplify it and they
start out
doing this they say putting just a
single line they say okay
so here we have the atoms right the blue
ones the are the
protons those are the positive charges
and you have all these
electron beads moving from atom to atom
a flow of electron beads
that's what these people think is
a a current
okay and what's the problem with that
well uh
right off the bat we have a a problem
because we have this
planetary atom which they're using i've
got the colors in reverse on the bottom
but it's the same and like i said the
other day
we've got a problem with that adam they
cannot imagine their atom
it's an unvisualizable unimaginable
uh beyond reasonable
uh atom you cannot imagine this atom
because you cannot
tell me why that bead doesn't fly away
but this is the atom they're going to
use
to do their electricity okay and they're
going to create this field
whatever that is so so we have a concept
called the field that's surround because
they're going to talk about the magnetic
field
so we have this concept called a
magnetic field which somehow
exactly exerts forces on
charges maybe or whatever you put near
them which is char a charged object
right and so if it's gonna
produce uh an effect a physical effect a
measurable effect
one that you can see you can you know
more or less touch you know
if if it can do that then it can't be a
concept
you can't say well the field is a bunch
of numbers surrounding the wire
that's where the problem that's the
first problem the second problem is this
adam again
you know uh it's an irrational atom but
that's the one they're gonna use
and then they're gonna deny it at the
end of the show you know that at the end
of the show they're gonna say well
i was just kidding okay
uh what is your real adam could you show
me your real atom and do your
electricity with your real
atom and yeah that's where they bomb out
that's why they never do that they
present their uh
their comical
atom they're niels bohr uh ernest
rutherford adam their planetary atom
they're going to do ionization with that
they're also going to do
quantum jump they're going to do
electricity with that and then they're
going to deny it at the end of the show
yeah don't pay attention to what i just
said
you know uh because that's not a real
atom
so uh why did they say that to begin
with they should have said look this is
the atom that i'm not gonna use that i'm
gonna use but it but it ain't
that's the way they should present these
things okay so where do they move from
there
both because both of them explain almost
identical okay
in an identical way they say well
imagine there's a cat
in the case of uh mr derrick
and here i'll put also side by side
mr lucid okay he uses a squirrel
and they say what if you have this cat
or this squirrel
and it runs together with the electron
beads
okay so it runs at the same speed as the
electron beads
okay so now they say well
you're approaching close to the speed of
light you know
these are very fast speeds and now we
can introduce special relativity in this
context
it says because now we're going to use
frames of reference which uh special
relativity is famous for
okay and so this is one way that you can
look at it
here's another way that you can look at
it uh this is mr
um muller again and side by side with
uh mr lucid and what we're gonna do
we're gonna hold still
all the electrons and we're gonna hold
still the two little animals the cat and
the squirrel
and we're gonna assume that they're in
their frame of reference in other words
they're they're on earth and you're the
guy who's running around
okay so if you're on the uh protons on
the
blue ones there well you're gonna be
moving in the opposite direction that's
the way they see it from their point of
view
so from our point of view you see the
electrons and the cats
and squirrels going to the right and
from their point of view they see you
going to the left
all the protons and you going to the
left okay
but there's an added effect here that
you may have missed so let's put it up
there so that you can see it
okay if you see those protons you can
see they're
they're spaced out there's a certain
spacing between the protons
but since they're traveling at the speed
of or close to the speed of light
as they go to the left you see there
that this not only do they flatten out
because remember you have length
contraction to the left
but you also will have distance
contraction
there's going to be contraction of the
spacing between the the
protons so you're going to see it more
like this okay
let me lift this one a little bit so
that you can see this a little better
okay so it's gonna gonna be like that
okay you can
compare them you can see the the protons
are closer together
okay and here's uh mr lucid with his
squirrel
also uh same thing
let's see if we can get the squirrel up
there as well
lift it a little bit can you see what's
happening here
okay so so so what's happening is that
uh let me lift this one here okay so
this is what you see
okay you see uh that uh while you were
standing still
uh the protons are going to the left but
the top uh
[Music]
diagram there shows that they're going
uh faster
or or the distance between them
shrinks and so and by the way they uh
the protons also
are allowed to flatten out you know
because supposedly anything traveling
close to the speed of light
uh gets shrunk in the direction of
travel
okay uh one fell says the same thing uh
no they're not the same thing if that's
what you were asking uh
if you look at the bottom you see uh
that the protons are closer to
each other whereas the ones on the top
they're a little spaced out a little
a little further they're almost the same
but just
notice that difference there okay and
then um
uh so so what's next well what's next is
this
you have now if i can get this thing up
there
okay um not only do the uh
proton balls get uh closer together
okay because that's the way the cat sees
it but the
electron balls which were before they
were moving like
up there you can see oh well no i had it
in the previous
thing but the electron balls were moving
the cat was moving with the electron
balls
now the electron beads those red ones
they are also spaced out more because
they're not being flattened out closer
to each other like when
they were when they were traveling at
close to the speed of light
okay so let's see if we can show you
that comparison
um here it is see the one
this one moves uh with the cat
and so the electron beads have a certain
distance between them
but here you can see that the electron
beads are farther apart
okay and of course uh same thing
uh for mr lucid okay so let me get this
one up there so that you can
see each one with his own animal there
so we have a couple of effects we have
uh the electron beads are really the
ones that are moving
together with a cat and with a squirrel
they're moving to the right
however because we're going to look at
their frame of
reference the frame of reference of the
cat and the squirrel
they see the protons going in the
opposite direction
they see them going close to the speed
of light that means that according to
special relativity
the distance between the electron uh the
proton balls
uh shortens and um
and on top of that you have a double
whammy because the electron beads which
were
uh shrunk in the direction of travel in
other words
the distance between them was shrunk is
now normal as far as the cat is
concerned okay so from his frame of
reference
um you know it's a little wider than
what it would be for you
okay so that's what they wanted to show
there okay
so we get the picture that's the general
picture
okay and here's a summary of that in
case you uh
missed it okay
okay and let me put something up there
before i explain that
which is going to be the summary okay so
these go together
and so what does mr lucid say well he
says
how does special relativity fix
electromagnetism yeah good question
what does it have to do with it by
allowing measurements to change
between points of view so
uh are we talking about physics here are
we talking about what the observer
thinks he saw okay so this is another
issue that is always introduced
into mathematics and that's why general
relativity is called
relativity because the relativity part
has to do with
observers opinions eventually that's
that's ultimately what they're they're
saying and mr lucy continues he says
in the lab frame he he had um
the lab frame and the clone frame the
lab frame was essentially
when the squirrel moved with the
electrons okay and the clone frame is
when the
uh essentially the um
what is it the uh squirrel stood still
together with
the electrons because they were in their
own frame of reference okay
so he says in the lab frame the moving
electrons use a magnetic field to exert
a magnetic force on the squirrel
and that's the image on the bottom left
on the on the on on the
picture on the right okay in the clone
frame the electrons expanded and the
positive bits contracted
okay this left the wire charged allowing
it to exert an electric
force instead the squirrel is repelled
by the wire in both frames
magnetism is just electricity in a
different frame of reference
so what is he saying he's saying that
they switched around in other words
he says that what is magnetism to
you who was observing the uh
squirrel moved by is
to him is electricity and
to you it's magnetism that's what pushed
the squirrel of
farther away from you for the squirrel
it's electricity that pushed him out why
because he says
or this is their theory that all these
positive charges those protons come
together
and there's a more positive charges
uh in that region and because there are
positive charges it pushes a positive
charge
as this little um squirrel away
okay and in the case of the cat
who's also positive okay mr derek says
more or less the same thing he says
there it is he says
in that in the cat's frame of reference
it is repelled from
from the wire due to the electric field
created by the excess
positive charges produced by the effects
of length contraction
okay in my frame of reference the cat is
repel
repelled from a neutral wire due to the
magnetic field generated by the current
flowing in the wire
so whether you see it as an electric
field or a magnetic field
just depends on your frame of reference
so
an electric electromagnet is an everyday
example of special
relativity in action
what are these folks saying well they're
saying that
if uh if you're looking at if you had
the eyes of god you could see
electricity right here
flowing through you okay that flowing
through in front of your eyes
um assuming they they go to the left
okay
uh to your yeah to your left okay it's
the same
uh let's let's go to the left the
electrons are flowing to the left okay
and uh so what you're seeing is
or the reason you see that a uh
squirrel in this case or a cat
positively charged
squirrel positively charged cat or
positively charged whatever
the reason it's being pushed away is
because there's a magnetic field
okay spiraling around the wire
what is a magnetic field well it's it's
that thing that they don't know
it's just a bunch of numbers okay great
so that's what's pushing
the cat and the squirrel away right
but under special relativity you got to
put yourself in the
uh in the position of the cat and the
squirrel
and you gotta look at it from their
point of view like if they're standing
still and what's moving
is you together with the protons okay
so you're moving to the right together
with the protons
and because you're moving to the right
and the protons are coming together
because they're
moving at close to the speed of light
that means that the distance between
them shrinks aside from the fact that
the proton itself flattens out
then what you have is more protons
per unit uh length okay
and if you have more protons protons are
positive and somehow
the proton field electric field whatever
that is
what was the field we don't know just a
bunch of numbers that pushes
that's what pushes the uh the little
kitty
and the uh squirrel away
okay so that's how special relativity
somehow now
is part of electricity i guess all the
electrician will now have to learn
special relativity in order to
understand a circuit
okay yeah it's uh quite crazy and uh
so all we can do is provide the
alternative
and uh here it is i explained a little
bit the other day here i'll just
rub it in once more okay we start with
an iron atom
we're going to assume that the wire is
made of atoms
iron atoms and it looks somewhat like
that but
it's complex but all those are
uh those are actual balloons they're not
uh orbitals as quantum mechanics has it
they're actual physical balloons
okay and so we're going to look at the
outer part of that balloon
you can see that it's divided into uh
six
little things that are sticking out
those are
again balloons those are membranes okay
weaved by the electromagnetic threads
that
uh formed a rope okay all the ropes in
the
universe converge upon our atom they
split out and they start weaving
this little atom okay
and um so now we're gonna take a bunch
of these
uh uh iron atoms
and we're gonna put them together okay
because they merge
the uh electro the threads
uh electron shells as we call them are
balloons and they merge okay they merge
and that's a long story we do have an
explanation for that but it's
beyond the scope of today and so what
happens they merge
they form what you see on the top uh
they form
a these molecules essentially you know
these long strings
of atoms which are merged we call them
serpentines
okay and what you see on the bottom you
see that the serpentine is going to spin
okay it's going to spin in situ okay
so now if we put this on our circuit
okay you're going to see something like
this okay as soon as you uh
close the switch okay you're gonna see
the snake uh contorting all around
okay and it goes in both directions okay
goes uh what if we're going to use the
negative positive
or the multiplication and division signs
whichever one you want to use
north and south pole whatever uh it goes
through both posts simultaneously okay
under the rope model so we don't have to
wait for the little bee to make it all
the way around
now instantly the this acts like a
little snake
that has its head touching its
tail it's wound around in a circle or
square or whatever
and it twirls on itself okay so that's
the notion of
electricity we have under the rope model
and yeah as soon as you
close the switch you can see that
everywhere
it's simultaneously twisting around
okay so there is no delay between
one pole and the other okay and what
this allows us to explain is that
there's a difference between a magnetic
field
and a an electric field because there
are two different
mechanisms totally different mechanisms
and this is where these people have it
so wrong everybody who uses these uh
these little um particles and trying to
do everything with
uh the planetary model of the atom and
this is what it looks like more or less
again i showed it list the other day but
it's essentially
um when when the
uh the atom
spin the uh uh what is it the iron
uh serpentines they're all connected you
know they're spinning situ
when they do that they release threads
those threads are the ones that swing
around
and those swinging threads is what
we call a magnetic field that's why it
exerts a force because
there's something physical in there
that physical uh thing is the
uh the threads hundreds of
billions of threads and uh or like
mr faraday said you know uh he said in
that region it's uh
we have um there's a physicality to
those threads
okay you have or or maxwell also said he
said
what you see there is matter in motion
he was talking about obviously a
an exotic type of matter that he
couldn't even
imagine right fathom and uh
yeah uh under the rope model we proposed
that what they were seeing all this
all these years were all these threads
that were spinning around
you